everybody was going out welcome to
Monday man yeah how's everybody doing
all right guys we're very excited this
week we've got the cast of those who
can't Ben Roy Adam cayton-holland and
Andrew or Vidale with as always as Beth
in the corner we made her sit the corner
this week hey man do your thing there we
go today we're gonna play a bunch of
dumb games the first one is gonna be
gang beefs now none of these guys play
video games right no idea you believe it
okay shady fridge that's for the
shoutout
look at this that's right Lou lafawn
what's up not a furry red panda yay
welcome reality perfect uh yeah so here
we go so we're gonna play gang beasts
which is uh ridiculous and fun I'm gonna
be what are you doing with you you're a
deer you had a little box thing the King
I don't know what that is this I'm using
a steam controller and this thing is I
don't know with this done this has like
touch pads and oh that's like the majors
frickin scary all right everybody I also
don't know what we're gonna play so the
idea here is just to beat everybody else
yeah and I don't really know what we
play two five so uh what does he do oh
no yeah there's a jump although all the
controllers are different so if you
punch and you look drunk if you figure
out the punch thing you can also then
hold it and grab somebody I think you
can if you figure out a pan I'm off
again yeah exactly
someone after you I got the Kate white
none of my buttons my buttons right on
triggers try the triggers others no no
yeah
you want you want just by wandering
around lassic classic I'm doing the
rope-a-dope yeah
now if you punch and if you hold the
punch button you can grab someone to
drag around yeah he's he's like Michael
Douglas's Pauly house but grabbing my
mustache oh oh that was vice do it then
no wait all right you guys all play
teachers on those who can't yes yes
which is who are also terrible role
models for the students yes then your
your history teacher is extremely
violent yes or no yes yes this is I
don't think he's passionate okay say he
has Bashan issues yes do you guys come
on
did you guys are these teachers based on
anyone that you guys had growing up just
our worst character no there I go again
it's based deep with it oh no I did one
of these teachers growing up gotcha
no I'm by the Cape oh how do I get off
the ah there we go
Andrews got the scolding parent move
yeah he says no you do not come here you
do not you getting the calls a bit of an
advantage because he took Krav Maga oh
my god
Pro Marius stay down crab rangoon today
I love Jeff stay down stay down
well you know Crum that's what Batman
uses his Krav Maga is that it's a is
that the thing where you got show them
your armpits and your yard of dirty
fighting yard of dirty yeah it's like
learning
I think I think I don't know who's oh
yeah over you to my death language
[Laughter]
there's like no thought I could fly
he thought it could fly
[Laughter]
wait so it's just with Kron McGraw it's
just basically dirty fighting that he's
totally dirty sick throw your keys it's
like he's always jokes like like
throwing out the art of throwing a lamp
at someone yeah teach you to use stuff
in your surroundings to hit people oh my
god yeah I catching like shopping and
graduate yeah like before I did I'm the
guy I thought I knew how to properly
kick somebody in the nuts but after
after you learn the finer points you
really learn the take what gotta come
from beside soccer style everybody get
agreement hit the green button
yeah you could select what is no what if
I want to kick somebody in the nuts just
of all you're not aiming for the nuts
you're aiming for the top of their head
they're nuts way god painful deep cut is
very painful I'm going die no weird
futuristic wrestler this guy's about
love
exactly oh yeah I have something badass
a lot around schools by plane pilot
crop-dusting yes so he said I have this
bound to my thing but I don't know what
this means up here this is crazy
just bring a big ball out yeah big NPC
what is what do you do yeah you get
someone's gonna come in in a costume
buddy sorry there for smash brothers
grinder for fur the hell am I
somebody says super smash brothers like
live fire wait where'd my hat go took my
hat but anyway yeah this Jonas is not
going back to what you asked it's not
based on any fair threads like any
teachers they're like kind of the worst
parts of our own personality I did have
a violent teacher in fourth grade that
my PE teacher she whoa pick me up by the
neck my mom doesn't match the triggers
and they don't do anything yeah what you
can we gotta get somebody in these
flames yeah oh so let's go into the burn
on this button celebration celebrate
let's sleep what I think up here it's
intriguing to me I'm gonna try to get
something going on balls Oh somebody
just says balls up here I got you oh
there's a move balls did you find a move
or something or I'm dancing again oh
they're balls you know I guess somebody
who just threw a couch at us who are we
we are the cast of a show on truTV
called those who can Thursdays at 10:30
Thursdays asking 9:30 central what I'm
looking at them people are asking
questions I'm trying to I'm trying to
win look how dead my guy looks like a
hey my door we got a big guy oh hey we
have a new enemy we all have to band up
and fight this guy had a big hero 6 the
game history is somebody blind who's man
look at her gothic glass oh this guy
joking you a body just like battle of
the used car dealership sales technique
might be inflatable yeah exactly
anything goats I mean let's see who
shoot wait then who are you
guy Oh your light blue yonder and ER
super bear your green I'm the purple and
force of love purple forceable I can't
be described as a fire
I've been trying to do a Care Bear stare
for five minutes trace menu things if we
can look here's some meat Oh guys
depends on the conveyer belt don't let
him back oh oh god I got the big guy on
me do this big guys a grip this big guys
really are you going
[Laughter]
let's see if we can toss this green
cream sure - yeah buddy yeah me too
I want to go up to the DJ because I want
to kiss him du hast guy in the fire that
was your go to you went us on the fire
and passed out you know what's good be
this I'm gonna leap into the fire do it
see tell us how it is I think there's
more stuff ahead here let's see a
dumpster
all these carry a martyr blow me your
shopping it's kind of so we got some you
guys you guys are a well I get were or
are the growl --ax the garlic's is we're
all stand-up comedians but we started a
show together in Denver and started
making sketches sketch comedy online how
did you guys actually meet I met Ben at
a bar one night we were both both there
hanging out and he's like I'm a stand-up
comic and I was like that's cool I've
never met a stand-up comic and then a
week later I went to an open mic and
that's where I kind of met Andrew at
that open mic so all authors stand-up
collar nice this Denver was a much
smaller scene years and years ago and oh
look at that get him on the phone a
little get him on where it's given that
get him on the ball somebody says we
should add some cocaine get him on the
belt yeah yeah what's the option for
cocaine you have the controller I
literally suck controller
suck and blow today doing him having
mean what's he doing side suck and blow
was Oh
we're gonna add a bunch of I'm that guy
in a voice I'm a guy that comes in late
and jumps on the head I'm adding so many
balls control you can ask all set of
look at these balls get me how do we
pick anybody out there you all whoa
balls are going crazy I'm hitting this I
know anything about this game yeah so
ever the blow
there's blow button there's a sus on
what is that what's that what's that big
break I was I could air humping me this
is I think of oh there's another
[Laughter]
conspiracy stuff ass head do any of you
guys actually have experience with
teaching I was a year and a half oh you
were I was a terrible sounds like I
genders get east high school right yeah
catch it a hard are it's terrible not a
soft are are terrible
wait no you you are substitute teacher
did anybody try to play pranks on you or
anything no I was just pranking myself
by making with ninety dollars a day tell
him about when we were in the school the
kids when you were using the bathroom
that pranked you oh yeah but when we
were filming those who began at Van Nuys
high school I went in there and
character like they kept saying don't
use the student bathrooms I was like
whatever I'm its closest to the place
where were filming to use the student
bathroom so I go into a stall and these
kids come in and they like oh we got it
just see me do it and they just get a
bunch of likes wet paper towel lob them
over into the stall five there's a
clumpy wet paper towel oh my I deserved
I get it I get it I was the douche bag
teacher I don't think anybody um you're
going to the flames both yet what slow
your flames flames
why because I heard this a lot yeah it's
just sugar it's kind of like
feeling that's a Brian Boitano move yeah
what's he doin what's he do he shouldn't
be a thing love he's Stewart neighbor
yeah it's good Oh what sound weird like
this thing that you know this game is
behalf of this genious I don't thinking
editorializing these games yeah more one
of the worst games ever
whoa there we go wait what's that more
boxes you said no problem how are you
doing that I'm here it's a weird guy
could go big ball again or a bunch of
them
yeah it's that what's the target Oh guys
oh it looks like there's a this is a
great metaphor for life you just go
around cluelessly while the
powers-that-be throw more [ __ ] jump
around right add more stuff
what is add more staff base people know
it um weather
oh there's anyone who want to meet get
some meat I was just down to Texas had
some roping put in the combo put in the
cop oh my god that's it count it's a
crit I can't do that combo it's like why
I be down Y X X Y be down we took out
the big grey guy we just can't keep up
the good work there eh
thanks JD you know crispy crispy crispy
keep it in Adams camp bro go in the
flame I'm watching black porn right now
these are not just interns where am i oh
there is a realtor boy you guys have
made a mess of this say my god whoa
you're going in the flakes
I'll be good um you guys got a butcher
special special guest Sarah Michelle
Gellar yeah Jane Miller
yeah Michael Madsen Michael Matt mr.
blonde that's Chris that was so weird
after watching Reservoir Dogs you know
like religious man
yeah he seems like a cool guy though
right
does he talk that's just his Mattson
voice I see my character I think buddy
yeah but don't I come back or get all
hopped it I think we have to die get out
Michael terrifying in the exact way you
want him to be oh my
hoot-hoot Matt's in play and it is a cop
well we don't want to spoil too much he
plays a cop okay yeah cops oh yes he was
the that's right hey I'm back in the
purple force of love oh yes I'm Aaron
Susie Essman was also uh yes Susie
Essman is shown she's so nice where I
was actually nervous because I thought
she was gonna be a lot like her
characters on Curb Your Enthusiasm but
yeah very sweet is very nice and funny
she's a great actress yes yeah she plays
the older home act teacher who has
tenure and get 500 Jeffy where's your
favorite class my favorite class
yeah growing up and really yeah in real
life yeah drama probably or English Oh
writing stuff I hate it's so funny like
I hated writing anything as a kid I'm
never like leftover lady yeah yeah oh
yeah for sure I wrote on the newspaper
real life gangs once I realized we could
just start writing on ioan articles and
top ten that sounds like they're getting
real-life games right go get their
characters real have babies yeah sorry
sorry about that
don't make me pull my controller where
am i dry hump you guys why fight it
right in your characters just
dry-humping half I was just trying to
drive up you once how's that no I got a
little oh I got a head butt down boom
look at him he's skank Oh like you said
over there oh oh I think everybody
fights it let's all fight in the
conveyor belt already on the conveyor
yeah there it is passing out Oh check
out this dance why'd you get off my
dance man
yeah ready get back on would you guys
ever consider really like like doing MMA
or like finding someone in the rink
Crossman Jiu Jitsu
whoa wait who would we need a fight
between you guys okay Wow though it's
like affinity of Krav Maga class has
been is it's like a lifetime fighting
all the time
oh my god really yeah but if you make it
so much my fight take out one of Ben's
eyes it is here oh I'm leaving oh yeah I
don't hang out oh hey can I wait I don't
wear like fliction stuff and they know
but you regularly wrestle with men on
the ground
I do wrestle with men and do Jiu Jitsu
and and I do yeah like I wanna be doing
this I took Japanese jiu-jitsu for like
like a terror six or seven years and
then I saw the submission wrestling and
whoa that's crazy
he JJ yeah but I submission wrestling
and BJJ yeah Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
okay what's the difference are you
talking you couldn't possibly confuse
any of those things for anything it lets
copy Javy yeah I'm in a submission be
JJ's what you guys don't gangbang do
miss of BJ's the best
hey yeah
about five years but we've known each
other for awesome and we did other types
of shows we had a group up most Krakow's
super hilarious hosted a which is
Spanish for Adam I'm trying to drag him
in the fire how long have we been
together
Oh somebody else yes yes and your
character is actually a Spanish teacher
C Mon C Mon yeah
I must have known Spanish si yo puedo
hablar no es solamente puedo hablar
español desde ahora hasta el fin de
Leeuw interview eyes now is that just
what respond you away go to we had a web
series you can I've been grabbing the
internet once crabbing forget your
question I'm what drew us to do in the
show we have get let go of my foot you
hear we're gonna get in everybody let's
go to hell together
let's all go to hell together so we out
of a web series that we would we did for
a while that we would post on Funny or
Die and then we decided to try to
develop that show which you can still
watch it's called the glow then we
decided to develop it as a TV show and
and we decided that school was a fun
environment for those particular series
I'm adding parties now the boxes are
coming in people are digging the Spanish
yes no a nice plan your list we Paku
Laden el Internet
here comes the meat Oh me here it comes
gotta be things interesting so oh I see
so the web series was actually just the
characters them several the the show we
the web series got kind of popular and
people were asking us if we had any
ideas for shows and eventually we hit
upon this script of us as teachers and
we just transferred our characters from
the way oh that's great right to those
who can so these characters have been
something we've been working on for
years they're just they're exaggerations
of our worst traits right we play
ourselves but just wave worser versions
of ourselves that's and what were some
the challenges adapting the webseries to
an actual
honestly like with the webseries it's
much shorter so it's easier to just do a
crazy sketch sure yeah chorus like okay
this character is gonna be drag this is
this scene just being goofy and then do
a whole half-hour show you're like ah
these things kind of need to track
across a whole episodes going right just
gonna make us a knee of choices because
in the world of the TV show it's it's
bad it confuses people
yeah well what were some of the like
influences you guys have when you like
what are shows that you liked that you
really go master good we good they know
if we could make our show like this this
would be fantastic
we all have a ton of influences I always
really like the Simpsons are usually
like yeah Seinfeld I think
scholastically we all like strangers
with candy oh yes we're big fans abroad
city like once do you remember the young
ones oh the young ones is that British
yeah remember that show there was a guy
there's like a punk out with a yeah come
through the wall nobody would just come
through the wall they're saying way
worse stuff in the internet thing It's
Always Sunny look at me just lay down
look at me lay down guys I'm ready to
grapple Ben are you dinosaur I'm the
blue no I'm the guy getting dragged
around by now if you guys were all into
being furries and maybe you are what
would be your free shows you Thursday at
10:30 a.m. on truTV that's a question I
like I'd like to be [ __ ] as I don't
know I just feel like it'd be nice to
[ __ ] be [ __ ] as a pink penguins
yeah cuz they kind of don't get there do
this bread with birds my self-esteem
exactly only Bertha can't file
I guess the ostrich also yeah just stick
my head in the ground
and ER what about you furries I don't
know yeah it doesn't really I sit Furby
by the way but I miss ya hi [ __ ] for
bees it's a different
they're going down you're gonna go on
eBay I think a lot of vacations to Seoul
South Korea I would be the travelers
insurance umbrella they [ __ ] me take
it stick it insurance companies he took
it in he made it his own and you brought
it back who knows someone came in with
in it today years they're all from
they're all from Denver we're from
Denver and the show that's right those
who can't you can dolls
what's that this is like somebody made
watch it yeah yeah yeah yeah if I hop
they can't catch me someone have already
thought I ran on the floor already saw
Lou how do that grab the collar move I
you you just hold if there's a punch you
hold it yeah there you go
you're the evil [ __ ] we're adam to said
the b-word
look at that I'm taking one I'll see
them come rescue welcome to really
getting those really okay all right here
we go
now we're gonna play a little thing
called move or die can these people play
us I think we could play move or die
with people yeah how do we do that let's
see here hold on Oh
somebody said effing and they got
blocked yeah that's only only weak only
we can be filthy
only we can be filthy oh my god good
play yeah I gotta say like ah
well see we put people around it's funny
we had a group known as should I call
the insurance company
wait to give you guys the hang of it
we'll play ourselves clothe ourselves
first select your character on TV so hit
a then Roy and Roberto Adam
cayton-holland it's right Thursday
nights 10:30 9:30 central 10:30 9:30
central that's right today hit at 8:30
mountain time
hey no 30 is oh no bro wait nine thirty
days Eastern 8:30 s mile or two hours
behind these guys whoa one hour ahead
then what central rule essentials one
hour head of that I mean what like where
would a central person win Michigan no
Michigan is okay okay Wisconsin we
scored
what's going on the time in this country
believes broken up into zones oh yes I
don't understand
yeah I'm going skelling - I think all
right you're ready we got two skeletons
and two brains all right all right - hit
ready hit ready go down hit ready Oh
pick whichever skin you want yeah pick a
skin yeah now this game is just you want
to survive you got to keep moving
because when you stop your life goes
down there's gonna be every game has a
little weird thing so the change is real
yeah and also this guy is a super creepy
sounding dude wait so someone could
select the mode if they want you're just
hit a
Hey yep color crazed you can select
another one if you want I guess yeah yep
Wisconsin is still estate good question
here we go shout out to the old fashion
in Madison that tried to kill us but we
kept cheese curds he's creating a
cheeseburger are you wanna paint as much
of the thing so whoever gets the most of
their color on the on the on the board
wins blocks yeah buddy Tyler and if you
stop moving you're colorblind yeah it's
like today yellow I don't know who's
yellow I'm yellow
oh no but babe it's the winning them
what's everyone's color I'm dreaming I'm
yellow purple green yellow purple pink
our area what if I wasn't colorblind but
I just didn't know the names of colors
well I'm blue maybe your color boy yeah
I do yeah definitely come on come on oh
oh
smear discolor all over that guy's
smeared my color all over that ground
[Laughter]
yeah hey baby you want to go smear some
color around my devices Mir my
color all over your ground wait are you
guys all married what's the deal Jerry
Jerry divorce I'm engaged
Oh congratulations we're all the stages
of grief oh my god that's single so
we've done the whole oh yeah yeah
evolution event oh my god that's great
I've got a son I've got a child your
daughter you have spawned yeah I see
this out there the world
yeah I've spread my brain all over the
ground so I'm getting more - yeah
meanwhile it's yeah it's just video
games for me
move or Die video yeah did you ever have
any hot teachers oh yeah I think that
happens for real in college or high
school high school I'm just trying to
see how pearlies guys just to stand firm
I was just trying to determine how pervy
the story was he was on the mission DJ
how you died you got I think you did you
didn't move
wait that's how do people know that she
that or he hooked up with the student
was it in the paint it must have been no
all the kids knew when she ended up
being whoa that's crazy
we were kind of bummed because the the
student that she hooked up with was not
all that I had so many more blocks than
your who was that who won that was I I'm
pink I'm green and I drink not so you
was a little - yeah I would say
incredibly - oh yeah I used to I had a
huge crush she was my drama teacher and
she was so hot maybe you know that's the
thing is I feel sometimes like hot girls
like all the hot girls I went to school
with ended up getting with kind of like
boring dudes maybe because they've had
oh it's all so it's just like girls and
anybody that peaks in high school yeah
gonna have it in terrible 20s and 30
yes that's true so it's like all the hot
girls I wind up with the bald loser guy
this is true if you were a hot winner in
high school what you're done yeah
exactly you peaked at 16 17 that's it
good luck with the rest of it yeah it's
only down now the white key it's only
downhill who's this person had a crush
on their geography teacher whoa hear
that really no features hook up with
their students hey no I could just do
two it's just not as like you know if
you're touching the other person almost
winning almost winning I don't do space
but MUFON says why do why do teachers
hook up with students I don't know
that's a good question
I mean fish in a barrel I guess right
yeah yeah they're all the time
I think it's dirty for each for it seems
like for men it's a lot more like yeah
I'ma be true oh my god I can't play this
anymore we have to switch this yeah all
right yes we have if you want I could
just run it back and forth across oh my
gosh I can't my green all over this
couch why do Americans care so much
about sexuality because there's people
man yeah we're just people you know we
were discover you know there were a lot
of Quakers and says the history teacher
says the yeah right
have you actually learned anything about
Hitler do you know history yeah I like
reading about it what's what's it
interesting what's it what's it
interesting historical fact we're the
Spanish teacher on the show well let's
talk about Savannah's history oh I like
history I read a lot I like mostly
Western history and Native American
stuff and then I was really in the punk
and hardcore and you had to read all of
like Howard Zinn like this oh yeah
people assisted yeah it was like
required reading if you were good
oh my god go oh death touch there was
hard core was an option whoo all right
so if you die yours can kill others by
touching them yes and then so this gay
time these are all different modes I'm
not sure with this
I'm dead I think that means you can tuck
you can kill other people though I think
what happened but time just by touching
that this game is nuts you might switch
to another I'm amazing and blowing
others might be today you took me to
your BJJ I'm a nicer Q there oh my god
oh now we all changed us here we go whoo
I feel like this experience is what life
in Japan is like all the time yeah who
is yellow this is going to class the
exact same pay attention yes killing all
this hologram in murdering and what was
I didn't die did you kill more people
look at everything
I think we're crying there's something
I'm yeah all those tricep for the game
is is already on the air if you have
cable it's on demand you can watch to
catch up yes as the show airs Thursday
at 10:30 on truTV there and you can also
watch episodes truTV calm yes the cable
oh is that true yeah I think clips you
can get on iTunes you can buy it on
iTunes oh there we go
maybe a high gimme the kitty say hi to
you I'll stay hiding thrice hello 8:30
Mountain give me the candy 7:30 the west
coast uh Hawaiian loves South Korea
somebody's who is the star the three of
us are the stars of the show as well as
a wonderful actress named Maria fair ran
right here I'm strangers with candy and
Eagleheart
that's right absolutely she's the best
for getting yeah Mary Lynn Rajskub and
we were talking about adorable kitten we
were talking about some special guests
you guys have had on one of peter
stormare yeah from the big lobotomy
dating he's on this week's episode right
so nice oh my way it's really the nicest
guy yeah in this week's episode we have
Mary Lynn Rajskub and Peter Stormare and
his character is bananas yeah he is I
love
I mean he's incredible and it's really
cool that he seems like a nice guy cuz
he seemed I want to go friend okay still
so like
speak Swedish normally and then like
when you interact it's bad accent really
you're seeing in the movies like is the
real that's the real deal he's the
Beatles so he was like he's like you
guys like the Beatles were like of
course the Beatles and then like next
thing you know he's emailing us Beatles
clips he's like live while my guitar
gently weeps thanks Maddie el84 you may
not have heard of us but that is why
we're here that's why we're hyping the
show that's right those who can't
it's about teachers you probably
shouldn't be teachers maybe even worse
their students or definitely our names
Harry Potter Harry Potter from Harry
Potter Harry Potter Harry Potter I'm
Harry Potter
my name's Ben Roy this is Andrew orbital
and that's Adam cayton-holland this game
is called mystery location oh here we go
420 bang it out erasers response let's
do this I don't I've never played this
game before so this is gonna be really
interesting game like quick we like that
alright everybody hit a at the there we
go okay okay
oh yeah being a bird who captain fist I
like this dude he's like make sense all
makes I will say like it was super fun
to design video games cuz it's like okay
fun fun to tune in it is a good show now
we're talking alright here we go so
basically there's here we go so trigger
is gonna be your gas ex is gonna be like
firing a weapon and then kind of except
right trigger accelerating L is steer
meaning this is left fire yeah I think
it's just when you run over things then
you could just hit X and shoot about
other people and try not to run off the
track you have to configure it first
though oh okay I made press day there we
go and I've already run off the dragon
and it's ridiculous
yep and here
back we come back why does it not have I
don't like no yeah all over this thing
yeah wait it might be atrocious yeah
here we go I don't know where I am I
don't know who I am or wherever what's
going pretty fun game this is yeah
that's great
my just beers yeah mines alone hi I'm
sliding all away play crappier yeah this
is this is this game is come see how
fast wait wait okay wait wait all right
here we go figure out this game nice
thinking about getting a steer I am I
can see my little okay I got me I'm
anyone that's me I'm - right yeah okay
I'm - no I'm - I'm - I'm tree head
remember I'm the weird clown hello am I
here as number six cube number seven oh
no wonder I've been nothing you have
numbers over there on the right yeah I'm
20 I'm 20 warm up that the magic with
the name of the character I see yeah
yeah yeah I'm over stimulated yeah this
is like what happened you do yeah so
stimulated right now I'm at full baths
wait where are we oh behind computer
games in would awaken decades Oh
crossing guess who made it through suck
it yes you did not there comes a weapon
Oh oh my god nailed it's like wow well
done as long as I stand stare at my
character I can kind of tell it's
happening yeah exactly
see I feel of this is like what Japan is
like yeah like the high-five Japan well
then this is worth the 15 hour plane
ride come on we were just over we were
actually just over in Korea we just shot
an episode over there yeah and it weighs
I mean I've been I've been there oh
really what I liked it where did you go
weasel oh man yeah we were just in Seoul
did you end up going to the DMZ I went
that we drove
we did like yeah they on there it was
like yeah it was crazy but yeah we was
if the video game culture is real there
I mean they love like oh my god it's
just yeah it was absolutely
captain fizz weapon collector maybe we
tried just one more of these and then
give this the boot
cuz this kind of seems like it was ion
left you look much older in real life
oh would that be me I don't know let's
see your let out left how on the couch
or on the screen I think it would be me
I do look older in real life you look
great
no I think you look you must moisturize
or something you got great skin well
thank you and you know what it's open
mouth but you do it translates well I
mean when your head is this tiny that
that good that good skin that would
awkward that good skin makes a it makes
you look amazing well thanks guys guys
let's talk about morning routines you
guys moisturize are you annoy strip I'm
not moisturizing you guys whether we
also are sitting in beard evolution yes
we thank here he usually has a mustache
yeah oh yeah sure sure joke if that were
the progress on a doodle baby or I joke
they never said that because it's not
that funny
that's I gotta say like it must be kind
of fun to be such good friends and work
together every day it's just a treat if
there somebody just got me some beard
oil I tried it for the first time and I
was like I don't want to put this crap
in my beard yeah rubbing oil I don't
know I don't use beard oil but maybe I
should does yours get much thicker than
that yeah it gets pretty thick but the
thing is like I think as it gets thicker
like I give a beard drift yeah I get bad
beard riff and then so you know so maybe
I should use oil yeah it's gross it's
like dandruff foot on your face which is
awful
what's Coco bot gonna get dry skin yeah
that's it's it's the worst we know could
of the Rocky blitz Rocco for the writer
strike years ago is the first time I I
had a beard and I just let it grow for
like four months
and eventually I just had like a wig on
my face like in the morning you ever do
that have you ever done like what's the
longest your beards guy
I usually this kid pretty long for me
right now I like to trim it about this
stage but I sometimes depends that
depressed I am fair enough so is this
it's depressed when you have a long
beard or when you have a shirt long
who's ever said yeah I don't know I
don't know you don't get up and trim
your beard
I like this level this is very mad max
yeah this feels a little you can't fall
off which is good
exactly okay yes you're with we are with
the cast of those who can't truTV
10:30 Thursdays I just ran into a mine
what about Ben Andrew whoa look out I
just showed you all my ass you're just
you're just on the show do a sit-up
I did I did Conan a few weeks ago yeah
that's a band
how about Carl Reiner oh my god then I
just died how is that it was very cool I
mean that's pretty awesome yeah he was
so nice he's like he was doing a segment
afterwards and he watched my set and he
complimented it and it was the cool oh
my god that's awesome yeah I got a cool
photo with Carl Reiner which says I've
been tattooing over social media who of
your have you guys got it got to met got
to meet any of your heroes Oh through
the show or just personally I went
through the show I mean maybe
everybody's hero's Michael Madsen I
don't know my god like some of them I
met I don't know why I gig out so much
over this but I I met that guy Joe said
who's a comic who owns side one dummy
record so I was pretty bummed about that
well that's awesome yeah I feel like
it's the it's the people who like mean
the most to us not the most famous Pete
right exactly
I kind of think it starts with the
people cuz you meet famous people all
the time you know I mean you see them
Mercer here and there a Sarah Michelle
Gellar was real cool it was kind of a a
mother thing in the same room face to
face but she was very down-to-earth and
nice and episode that's awesome Freddie
Prinze jr. and her husband came in and
played games with us he said I didn't
realize this she's a huge gamer is it
yeah yeah he plays like World of
Warcraft it was also a big jujitsu guy
as well oh really
he was like yeah
box our Junior Olympic boxer and stuff
and whoa yeah you and him who would wait
guys much smaller lengths lankier it's
got reach yeah no is he a submissive Jo
box iron BJJ at one point very creative
stuff you guys I appreciate you guys
making among other thing I did some
purpose in me mate thank you guys so
much I uh the coolest person I've gotten
to meet his is Conan oh there we go
twice yeah that would that would be
anything he could not be nicer yeah talk
about tall I'm such a big Simpsons fan
here I am he wrote several of us my
favorite episode of The Sims oh yeah
monorail is like I love monorail Homer
goes back to college oh my god great
episode and I told Conan about that
stuff and he's like yeah stop geeking
out yeah did he say that no he was just
you know appropriately self-deprecating
yeah one of my one of my friends night
Conan and like mentioned the monorail
episode and coda kind of said something
cool you know I always like love any
kind of Simpsons tidbits sure yes it's
like such a legendary show sure and well
done everybody
bastard and he said you know there's
that thing at the end where
what's-his-face disappears he's like or
am i and and that wasn't Conan's joke
that was added oh let the appreciate you
that episode I kind of you know it
always the ending always kind of seemed
like a little weak and then someone else
in the room came up but yeah you know
now that we write these shows together
you learn how room written the shows are
like everybody contributes to it yeah
Harrison Ford so when you see like the
name on the script it's just kind of
like some the room what they put there
that's awesome how much how much improv
do you guys do on Sunset or do you like
to cut out of 30% yeah give or take do
you leave some room in the day to kind
of let yourselves kind of play with some
takes and stuff or not
it's kind of built and we write the
scripts tight with jokes so that even if
we're you know you're just I'm having a
bad day long if you're having a long
period they're doing it you're like oh
maybe this is what is the weirdest thing
that has happened on the show you're
just things happened on the show you
mean in the show or while you've been
shooting the show ghosts
one of the weirdest things is it all set
at the end of the fairbell tape when
Claire vows to be carried by the
firefighter we didn't have a big
firefighter the people they cast were
like the same size grown-up caring like
a grown-up like hangin with a guy who
owned the fire truck who brought it was
an experiment and he was a giant so
we're like hey would you also mind
carrying this guy like a baby
he goes how much do you weigh and I go
about 155 and then he carried me and
afterward did you say 100 feet ready to
go like hundo five five trying to be
cool around the fire yeah yeah what do
you think maybe we finish that with some
gang beefs or do you want to play this
again I'd like to play this woman Oh
give it alright let's do it I keep
losing on this man what's your what's
your suggestion for staying on the
goddamn word you I don't know cuz I
accelerate and I'm trying to guide with
this controller on the left I just leave
it slips off the road more than you like
it feels like to be auto-fill with some
bots do we put this in make it crazy
yeah let's out a film let's just just
make this insane if we're gonna live in
the year 3000 this climate more relaxed
in real life or is he always weird
always weird yeah
always weird the answer of that here's
my favorite thing about how Conan's
different in real life than he is on TV
he's very very funny and his sense of
humor skews a little darker
yo yeah all right so everybody hit a
we're gonna see Batman vs Superman yes
and he used to do this thing back at
late night where he would come up behind
people and you know if you go like this
and your hands are dry it's like I guess
a little bit of a cricket noise I used
to come back and you go god you guys you
know what this is you know what make the
pressure I'm under and then you would
like walk away and it's really funny
it's really funny but very dark but yes
he had a really long depression beard
when he would say that yeah the one time
I met him he snapped a pigeon's neck
right in front of me
he'll die contact didn't say word more
of a zombie thing where am I
all right a voodoo thing no zombie thing
I am oh my I'm I think I'm eight I don't
know so yo Joe I found me I'm I don't
even know something I don't know this is
just nice to real the beat yeah this is
just great you know so often in LA you
don't get to the water and here we are
oh maybe I might be the red guy if
someone says change my shirt Pizza
doesn't suck well I'm trying to not eat
carbs so that's why it's did pump me up
you know what I'm saying what I'm trying
to say I lost 90 pounds so yeah and I'm
afraid of being a fat guy again hey I'm
lost a bunch of weight myself there we
go awesome good job yeah I mean that's
that did you have a thing where you're
like I'm afraid of getting fat for a lot
though that was not a while ago because
I mean if you're fat like a big big
heavy heavy dude like I was yeah and I'm
like it's 90 pounds you were probably
yeah a bit heavier as a monster also
emoji live in fear of like how you felt
not so much how I work there like it was
more for me like I didn't realize how
tiring it was oh that's interesting yeah
man they're carrying around a lot of
weight yeah and you're always tired like
I was always exactly I think I mean I
think I'm the taxi but my controls
although I cannot stay on the road to
save my goddamn life where are you
Michael literally it just will appear
and immediately we do me too oh hey guys
it's me I'm bad
I've only been playing console games for
the past two decades and I feel really
been oh oh my god
thank God I'm not a taxi you lost about
92 last year congratulations Wow
well done christopoulos well done I love
it a blitz Rocco says where can a man
get a manager good lord when you guys
are starting out well I'll send you mine
what would you say your big break was
did you guys have a moment where I was
like wow this is I feel like one another
level now I'd say the first one what for
me in 2010 was getting into the Just for
Laughs yes rial festival was like that
for stand-up comedy at that you know at
that level yeah yeah is if you if you're
a new face it's kind of like you're you
know like the big thing you want to get
into because there's so few comics to
get picked each year I compare it to the
NFL Draft
oh really yeah it's like you're you're
now in the mix whoa that's really cool
yeah Ben did it one year then I did it
the next thing Andrew did it the next
three years in a row oh my god I'll just
got two just for laughs that's awesome
out of Denver too which is easier said
than done
yeah I'm sure they don't even come to
Denver every year so what is what does
the comedy scene like in Denver it's
right it's really good yeah I mean we
have an amazing Club of the Comedy Works
tent town which is like one of the best
clubs in the country so many comics
record their albums there whoa the
classic comedy club like little basement
like oh that's great brick wall kind of
situation oh yeah but yeah the local
teenager's amazing I started doing sort
of an alternative scene we kind of
started it there doing chosen our
gallery wherever we get stage time and
that sort of everything but Denver is
the type of city that he's growing and
he's continues to grow it sort of those
type of I got you creative endeavors
that's cool excited to go check it out
that's cool I'm uh I'm from Michigan and
the Midwest I feel like has a good kind
of comic sensibility because there's a
lot of like weird repression there yeah
that like but then there's also you know
and so like is that is
kind of similar to Denver no like wires
no pressure problem like that's kind of
you know like in Chicago like you have
all these like weird kind of there's
definitely in the Midwest there's sort
of a well we're in for a long hard
winter yeah try to laugh at it instead
of cry yeah thick beer and like yeah
tiny endeavor it has some of that for
sure but Denver's definitely got so kind
of more Wild West like boom town
mentality which is like more more uh fun
which is very hard drinking but I did
Rewa pence I filled one out or pet pet I
don't know you say are you are a and
last month oh how did you guys how'd you
guys do this year are you all sports
guys yeah I like some sports I didn't do
a March Madness bracket I don't know I
just tried it for the first time I had
no understanding of how to do it but we
ride like yeah the background at any of
the teams I just tried to put one
together based on records like daddies
and I'm doing well and I feel like
that's how that's how people win oh yeah
people who don't know what's going on
there's like yeah they end up taking it
all the way it's always like Karen the
CPA in the back who knows nothing do
Dossett ak-47 yes we do have with legal
weed in Denver oh oh that's true
marriage a who've marriage and you want
to know what nothing is different yeah I
know it has changed I believe we just
just have more money yeah that's all it
is
yeah you feel like it's I'm I got a week
hard was not the patent that last year
but the year before literally just so
I'm not like a weed guy but just so I
could give it to my grandkids like cuz
it's gonna be no it's gonna be a real
girl you used to have to have you know
just like oh I thought you give weed
dear grandma can I give weed to my
grandpa
it's weird that I have grandkids I
adopted grandkids yeah
can you adopt grandchildren that's a
great I think let's go start that
website I bet your adopted grandkids
optigrill if you adopt okay if you would
Dobbin I'll mix some dirty grandpa
DeNiro kills three grandkids in that
forgot that my joystick doesn't work oh
yeah that's right cuz why would it why
would that would make too much sense
what a cool grandpa these situations I
love you guys
second a big kiss God you guys who's
joining us we're with the cast of those
who can't on truTV hey guys this
thursday peter stormare yeah Marilyn
Russ come are gonna be guest star this
Thursday's is the weirdest it may be the
weirdest episode of the whole season so
if you're joining it for the first time
you're gonna oh I want you to get hit by
this train how long how many oh you're
so funny some down there yeah no trains
come on that track I don't think oh yeah
they do it in that foreground track yep
Wow see if you can pull yourself up Oh
naughty boy down there no no no I can
grab maybe you could come you can come
on the side why am I trying to help you
[Laughter]
train is I fight in real life also
I just circle my opponent play leo oh no
that was great go alive oh no buddy do
you guys ever use any right any real
life things into yourselves into the
episodes
yeah all the time all the time he says
what is it do you have real or like real
life like you mean like like situations
or things or people even or no oh we
write real-life situations into the show
yeah yeah not not so much I I mean
they're pretty I think any teacher if
they had done the stuff that we yeah
I do in the shell would the dialogue
wise Wow
Hisoka my influences I mean are the
mascot of our show as a giant Oh
terrible he's alive you know it's is
based on who the school was named after
in the show so it's based on a
historical like thing like that yeah
come on get up get up and you know
honestly little like inside jokes that
we just like yeah and funny for weeks at
a time we'll find ways to like work
those into the conversations that the
characters are having just little
phrases we say or just little jokes that
we're cracking us up at the time we we
were come into the show the show
but uh the somebody asked about getting
it in Europe
oh no no like up oh you can get it in
Europe I can you yeah well they've like
it's on the TNT Germany and they're
doing they're doing the funniest ads
like their translations crack me up
there's a shot where the secretary like
knocks me through a wall no and they
made like I'm wrong yeah and they they
they wrote under it naughty naughty
little boy Paul Shaffers here are you
guys is there anything you guys wanted
to put in these episodes that you worked
it was too crazy or that I told you
couldn't do his give us amazing look
like amazing creative free no doubt pit
bulls here louisville worldwide yeah hey
miss worldwide hey come on now
yeah New Year's is the only night of the
year Christian Gentry this is called
gang beasts oh you just got your head
this is great you guys thanks for
watching tell your friends it means the
world
absolutely yeah Clark Kent Clark Kent
loves you guys oh Clark I hope you don't
get beat up by or I mean I hope your
friend Superman doesn't get beat up by
Batman and Ernie's do you got you guys
kind of like fans if you who are you if
you had to root for somebody who would
it be Batman oestrus I mean it's ridicu
and
you know basically anybody get up but
you I will say though Batman kind of
seems like a dick
hanging out with you probably be like
he's a guy if you got french fries would
like make you count out so you have
exactly the same number of french fry
like the posters where it looks like
he's gonna punch Superman wish there was
a poster for right after that whereas
like ruined yeah I don't need I don't
even understand why you would try to try
to fight Superman if you stay at Bruce
Manor Batman makes you make your bed in
the morning all the waiters
yes exactly he gets so piteous silently
glaring at you for not using I've always
kind of a boring Erica but why can't you
get up Batman is all those toys and
gadgets yeah but do you think you're
talking to oh man Jesus that's a flaw
that's a flaw you can't get out of this
Danny look out mr. Watkins Superman I do
like the fact that man it's like a
normal piece the world definitely I mean
a psychopath clearly I just think it's
an elastic argument Superman Boy Scout
right Oh weird
come on oh I think you know there's one
point where Tim Burton was supposed to
make a do you guys hear about this we're
like Nic Cage was gonna be Superman no
and it was supposed to be weird because
yeah how weird that he could hear
everyone which is kind of interesting
this is an interesting angle for
Superman where if you could hear
everyone constantly crying for help all
the time but you couldn't pick up
everyone so it's like [ __ ] ease get off
yeah you'd be like insane yeah how do
you get off the track everyone's like
Jesus yeah oh
versus Lois laughs I gotta go Lois Lane
at that one al versus last lane
kryptonite Oh kryptonite it's a pretty
big fly yeah but who's got kryptonite
you know well Batman sure been more like
a kryptonite suit or something right
exactly make sure he has that like weird
armored suit in the trailer and it's
like Superman throws train
he throws trains the heavier the suit is
the yes/no seed somebody's telling you
how to get it how do I get up grab both
hands pull down jump
okay so Oh all right I'm grabbing with
both hands
oh great and the Punisher is great oh
man I gotta see it Punisher outshines
daredevil you're like you're like I wish
the show is kind of just following right
he should Oh perfect oh it stopped oh
man yeah guys are computer games like
the bomb you have like a ps4 yeah yeah
that's the problem yeah exactly
oh my god it's such an in-depth game
then it's so realistic somebody was
trying to open Excel spreadsheet is you
know inside op Allah says that three
doors down has kryptonite oh my god you
guys are gang is this how the fights are
settled on the guy and I just know to me
this is from the gun you grabbing this
is prayer we should end today I don't
think it's gonna get better guys watch
those who can't a truTV 10:30 Thursdays
thank you to Ben Andrew and Adam for
coming and why go to a truTV comms live
shows flash those who can't follow them
on Facebook at truTV those who can't
yeah thank you for also the growl likes
how can you receive they want to see
some garlic stuff well so you'll be at
Sammy's in Nashville and April and then
will be a
Tempe improv a couple weeks after in
April as well and just kralik's comedy
calm right yes awesome
yeah fantastic thank you guys thank you
see you guys next week
you